-I'm not asking
for any spoilers,
because I would hate to
have it spoiled,
but is it then safe to say
because of who you're married to
and because of where it's at
in the process,
that you know how
"Game of Thrones" ends?
You do know. All right.
So, just look at Camera 1.
Look at Camera 1.
Don't say anything.
Just think about it,
and then we'll all go back
and watch this.
And we're going to try to
figure out from your expression.
Don't say a word.
Just think about how it ends.
-This is my poker face.
-Okay. Great.
-Are you ready?
-Yeah. Go.
-Okay. [ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God. That was terrible.
Oh, no.
That was a bad poker face.
-It's my drunk --
My drunk poker face
is different from
my sober poker face.
-They say that's why you
probably shouldn't --
-Okay, grandma?!
-You -- I did not know
this about you.
You are also a playwright.
You've written a couple plays.
-Yes.
-How -- I'm fascinated by that.
I'm impressed by that.
What is your writing process?
Is there a place you like to
write more than other places?
-No. It's just --
I don't have an office.
I don't -- I probably should
at some point,
but I don't do that.
And I -- It's really miserable.
-Yeah. Well, writing, I think,
no matter where you do it,
is fairly miserable.
I think there's --
Nothing's worse than
when people say,
"I just love to write,"
'cause I like to believe that
nobody actually likes to write.
-No, the problem with me is
that when I think I finish --
So, I did compare it
to childbirth,
because when I gave birth
to Molly, I --
Everyone was celebrating and
saying, "She's here, she's here.
The head is here."
And I breathed a
sigh of relief and was elated.
And then my O.B. --
Just her head just came over
and she's like,
"Now you just got to
get out the shoulders."
I was like, "Wait. What?
What are you talking about?"
And I'm not 46.
-"I am a young woman."
-Sheer disbelief that it takes
another round of effort
when you've already --
I just -- Yeah.
-The rewriting,
which is, I think,
when the best stuff
comes out of,
but it is a drag
to have to do it, as well.
-Yes, and it's
embarrassing to look back
and think that I thought
that I was finished,
and then, boy,
I wasn't even close.
-What a delight
to have you here.